[Musique]
aujourd'hui mardi 15 mars l actualité
dans les yvelines des prix qui ont
parfois dépassé les 2 euros le litre
depuis plusieurs jours la hausse des
tarifs des carburants fait la une de
l'actualité
le premier ministre a annoncé une remise
appliquée dès le 1er avril
quel impact pour les yvelinois dans la
partie rurale du département quelle
solution mais peut-il en place pour
réduire les factures renault poursuit
son avancée dans la construction de
véhicules constructeurs automobiles
proposent désormais des véhicules à
hydrogène
la première chaîne d'assemblage de piles
à combustible a été inaugurée
aujourd'hui à flins est un peu de
gourmandise que richard lett élève au
lycée hôtelier de saint quentin en
yvelines les 5 et 6 avril prochain elle
sera en finale nationale du championnat
de france du dessert 2022 nous sommes
allés à sa rencontre
[Musique]
ce mardi 15 mars dans cette station
service de magny les hameaux les prix
avoisinent les 2 euros le litre
malgré la facture salée pas question
pour emeline de mettre le frein à main
cette étudiante installé dans cette
commune rurale n'a pas le choix elle
doit faire le plein pour pouvoir se
rendre à son école ou à son stage on
peut plus se permettre d'aller
facilement voir de la famille des amis
sans compter les kilomètres mon attaque
faut que l'essence diminuent ce que ça
devient vraiment compliqué quelques
kilomètres plus loin chevreuse commune
de 5600 habitants difficile aussi de se
passer de la voiture les habitants ont
décidé de s'adapter à la situation et
tente de trouver des solutions chacun a
sa stratégie je m'entends selon me
paraît nécessaire ne pas trop sortir
avec le véhicule mais j'habite dans un
coin où en est pratiquement obligés
vous prendre une boîte lourd on essaye
quand même de repérer les endroits où
l'essence est un petit peu moins cher
on a deux voitures essence et on a une
commande d'une électrique aussi donc
voilà on en est là aujourd'hui bon le
trajet en voiture dans les communes
rurales ce gérant l'a bien remarqué
installé ici depuis sept ans il est face
à une situation inédite son nombre de
clients était divisé par deux je n'ai
jamais vendu aussi peu oui ça c'est sûr
en temps normal j'en mange jamais beau
flore n'ont pas beaucoup parce que je
suis toujours un petit peu plus cher que
total ou ou le carrefour de colère est
là depuis trois semaines j'en vois
encore moins parce que tout le monde se
dit comme il est un peu plus cher on va
tous donc là j'en vends très très peu en
première ligne face à cette flambée ses
habitants des communes rurales espèrent
désormais une baisse dans les prochaines
semaines le premier ministre jean castex
a notamment annoncé une remise à la
pompe de 15 centimes par litre de
carburant à partir du 1er avril et
pendant quatre mois
[Musique]
neuf mois après sa création il via
inaugure son usine à flins dans le nord
des yvelines en partenariat avec renault
et plug power cette usine représente la
première chaîne d'assemblage de piles à
combustible en france c'est pile
alimenteront les futurs véhicules
renault rno à l'évidence vous amène le
savoir-faire sur le véhicule utilitaire
et placards ouais c'est le leader
mondial de l'hydrogène nous sommes quand
même toujours focalisés sur les bonnes
solutions pour nos clients est ce que
c'est
l'électrique batali ou est ce que c'est
mais non hydrogène donc nous sommes
quand même pionniers à avoir les
meilleures solutions pour nos clients
mardi 15 mars renault yvias et plug
power ont révélé les trois véhicules
prototypes qui disposeront du système de
pile à combustible cette nouvelle
technologie permettra notamment aux
véhicules électriques d'avoir plus
d'autonomie un des intérêts pour le
client du type de véhicule utilitaire
c'est l'autonomie et la durabilité avec
l' architecture dual power on a en fait
un véhicule hybride qui utilisent le
carburant hydrogène soit pour créer
l'électricité qui propulse le véhicule
soit pour recharger la batterie pour
augmenter l'autonomie du véhicule
dans tous les cas avec cette
architecture dual power on va on va
garantir une autonomie l usage de
l'ordre de 400 à 450 km sur les
véhicules utilitaires légers soit la
pile recharge la batterie dans une
situation tranquille on va dire et quand
vous avez besoin de toute la puissance
la pile et la batterie alimente le
moteur électrique il y a pour objectif
de proposer mille système de pile à
combustion en un an
[Musique]
la france premier pays d'europe en terme
d'attractivité l'an 2000 21 les projets
d'investissements atteignent un chiffre
historiquement élevé c'est ce qu'a
annoncé hier franck riester le ministre
du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité s'est rendu aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines au sein de la british
school of paris et des laboratoires
mayoli spindler exemple de cette
attractivité une grève express sur les
sites français d'airbus à l'appel de
trois syndicats les salariés du groupe
étaient appelés à se rassembler le site
installé à elancourt où travaillent
environ 1500 personnes étaient aussi
concernées une mobilisation pour
réclamer une augmentation de salaire les
syndicats estiment que les propositions
de la direction sont indignes
[Musique]
bonnet de bain lunettes de piscine et
fret à la main c'est parti au centre
aquatique de saint cyr l'école sept
enfants s'initient gratuitement à
l'apprentissage de la natation vous
allez devoir
d'accord la crise sanitaire et la
fermeture des piscines ayant énormément
bouleversé l'apprentissage de la nage
vers marine a décidé de lancer
l'opération les petits nageurs on cible
particulièrement les enfants issus de
milieux modestes
parce que ce sont eux qui sont les plus
exposés ils n'ont pas forcément accès
facilement aux établissements comme les
nôtres et à des cours de natation privée
donc leur proposer sa solution de
rattrapage gratuite c'est très important
apprendre à se protéger du danger de
l'eau maîtriser les gestes élémentaires
et développer les bons réflexes voici
les principaux objectifs
beaucoup la flottaison
la propulsion donc ce soit sur le dos
sur le ventre l'immersion ça après c'est
les nouveaux principes de la natation
qu'on essaye de voir au fur et à mesure
et pour les parents et à la fin de la
semaine chaque enfant a reçu un diplôme
nautique garantissant ses aptitudes
là m'a appris à nager sur le dos mais je
savais déjà mangé sur le dos et on
devait mettre la tête sous l'eau jeter
c'est être bien
ouais que tu as appris j'ai appris comme
premier track hommage aux 1 2 3 soleil
et le premier qui s'étonne bully les
mines et du jeu au total dix mille
enfants en école primaire vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ces stages de natation
gratuitement en france au centre
aquatique de saint cyr l'école le
prochain se déroulera pendant les
vacances de pâques
[Musique]
c'était l'un des plus gros chantiers de
montigny le bretonneux le forum des arts
accueille depuis ce lundi 14 mars est
élève au centre aznavour les équipes ont
procédé au déménagement de tous les
équipements ces deux dernières semaines
deux formes d art construit sur l'ancien
collège henri bergson ses 3400 mètres
carrés dont les travaux ont débuté en
juin 2019 et un auditorium de 150 places
l'inauguration est prévue à la fin du
mois les 26 et 27 mars prochains 1800
élèves vont se font se croiser à 800
musique à peu près 1000 en danse
/ voilà par par semaine ce qui va faire
beaucoup de beaucoup d'émulation
beaucoup d'activités on va pouvoir aussi
du coup en profité pour croiser les
disciplines musique théâtre et danse
pourquoi pas un projet qui nous étaient
chers depuis le départ
d'articuler le bâtiment autour de
l'enregistrement en vertu des
enregistrements qui est articulée avec
un véritable studio cabine sont
d'enregistrement mais aussi un studio de
répétition et une salle du conservatoire
pour pouvoir enregistrer l'ensemble des
acteurs et pourquoi pas faire des
projets avec un choeur du conservatoire
[Musique]
chloé n'a que 18 ans et pourtant elle
compte déjà à son actif une
participation à objectif top chef ainsi
qu'une victoire à la finale régionale du
championnat de france du dessert 2022
dans la catégorie junior le 17 février
dernier les candidats devaient réaliser
en trois heures un dessert à l'assiette
pour 10 personnes sur la thématique de
l'expression de soi dans mon dessert on
peut leur trouver un prime et sésame
noir une pâte sucrée sésame noir une
chantier au lait ribot un sorbet à l'
orange des suprêmes d'orange
une tuile au sésame noir incrusté à mort
avec une marmelade d'orange chanteur et
un shell citron je suis partante d'avoir
gagné la finale régionale je m'attendais
pas du tout faire des concours c'est un
vrai j'aime bien parce que ça permet de
de faire quelque chose de différent du
service et de ce trophée au quotidien et
ça permet aussi de se comparer aux
autres si un peu de voir où est ce qu'on
demandait et tous actuellement élève au
lycée hôtelier de saint quentin en
yvelines à guyancourt elle est aussi
apprentis au restaurant étoilé la table
du 11 à versailles depuis quatre ans
c'est un dessert pomme sellerie donc on
retrouvera une brunoise de pommes et de
pommes granny smith mme de céleri
branche
unis lalanne est
avec un vinaigre de sap a réduit pour
faire une petite vinaigrette pour
assaisonner on retrouvera aussi un
biscuit au basilic un biscuit chambre et
de basilic un cerbère aux herbes
fraîches sur le dessus on aura un siphon
citron vert magic poudre d'estragon et
hino palin
grâce à sa victoire chloé s'est qualifié
pour la finale nationale face à six
autres candidats elle devra refaire son
dessert mais aussi un dessert surprise
avec des techniques imposées
le tout en quatre heures 50 pour la
finale nationale on se prépare dès qu'on
peut
parce que ça va être une épreuve qui va
durer quatre heures 50 falloir sortir de
désert ça va être long gagner le
concours national ce serait incroyable
quand même ça m'apporterait beaucoup de
connaissances je pense qu'il y aura
beaucoup de portes qui sauvèrent à moi
même et j'espère le gagner une finale
qui se déroulera les 5 et 6 avril
prochain au lycée hôtelier bonneveine à
marseille
[Musique]